action I think the challenge with every
action movie Always is the say we want
to see stuff that's never been done
before so on this one we wanted to raise
the bar and take the action to the next
level I'm most excited about the action
we're bringing to the movie I think it's
going to be above and beyond what we've
seen before it's going to be really good
classic Expendable style where it's a
little bit brutal but it has to be you
know real life is a bit brutal and this
film has that kind of edge to it
the Libya sequence is really exciting
cuz we really wanted to do a lot of
practical stunts and really put the
audience in an immersive environment
where the whole sequence was on the move
was written in the script to be on foot
and I'm like we got these cool vehicles
called a1s let's do the same action but
now on the fly in the middle of the car
chase have them fight it is just water
to wall action that's what I want from
these type of franchises when you get in
action film it's life-threatening
situations I think when people see it
feel completely real they get really
excited as spbe I tried to bring men and
women in from around the world on this
movie I had a team from Jackie chance
Hong Kong fight team I brought Steve
Kelo in from The Fast and Furious
franchise on car sequences and I brought
in Brian Smur from all the X-Men to
direct sector unit Brian Smur whoes a
genius when it comes to actual real
physical action he and his team have
designed some of the action pieces so
that you look at them and you go wow
that couldn't have been done for real
and it is for Real it was really knowing
the screenplay and looking at the visual
elements to not only talk about what I
wanted to do but also talk with Brian
about here's what we should collectively
do to elevate the sequence one of the
things that I try to bring to my films
is they're predominantly done for real
and I feel in today's climate that's
become an anomaly and we're doing so
much in visual effects that we're kind
of losing what action means and so for
myself I'm looking for new and exciting
ways that you've seen a car jaase but
how is this different we get to see some
of our new characters like Gan and Easy
in
action I need this for my
neighborhood we got all kind of stuff
going on back here real action scene we
out here doing it you going to love this
right here I'm out of ammo coming
in
action fireing the whole fell to Road
has always been an explosive expert in
all of the films this is the first film
where he actually gets to blow some
stuff up so obviously that excites me
quite a
bit the great part about working with
actors like Jason and Sly and Randy and
Dolph all these guys are able to
actually bring new things to the table
too and they see the choreography and
they put ingredients into the kitchen
and we make hopefully the best meal we
can with everybody's input the 12
amazing actors in the actual film it's
exciting to be there you got to surround
yourself with people that have their own
talents and their own style of doing
things Scott is actually the Mastermind
behind this we're super lucky to have
him I loved this movie Need for Speed
I've been a big fan of him for years I
actually watched one of his shows where
he just demonstrated how he lit and
filmed a car chase and he's bringing in
something extra special not just his
directorial style but also his humor his
freshness Sly and I been wanting to work
together for probably five or six years
so I was super excited to jump in and be
welcomed into this franchise and to
hopefully bring my kind of expertise
into this with my action background
Scott wants to hear your opinions and I
think that that Synergy really works
well with with the cast and the director
it's always great when you have a
director that knows exactly what they
want there's also freedom to play and to
experiment with different ideas and and
he's comfortable with those
experimentations which is again I think
important for this genre because
sometimes you find Magic on the day
that's not even written Andy Garcia and
I go back to 1996 we were doing a film
together called Desperate Measures and I
was a stunt double and because of what I
was able to do on that movie and get
paid to do it allowed me to fund my
first movie as a director and it was the
Catapult for my career and here we are
25 years later working with Scott has
been amazing he's been in the Stunt
World himself so like a lot of people
the audience can expect an amazing
action-packed cinematic movie what's
great about this movie is you have so
many performers who are experts in their
field Randy and I work out a lot
together and we're both Fighters I got
my first acting job because I was an
authentic fighter there's a authenticity
and a physicality that we as mixed
martial artists and Olympic wrestlers
have that you don't find in a lot of
other places you've got Tony jaw EO w
who are absolute Legends in the martial
arts movie industry it's like all these
characters are legit stuntmen and allows
me to shoot them without a stunt double
and really get the audience in the
action and also amongst the fighting
there's a big action sequence on a ship
at the very end of the story and so we
found a great location at the siki and
built a whole ship there we ended up
building the gentara deck out on a
chicken farm in Greece and we needed a
lot of room because the ship deck is
extremely big and long and that just
allowed us to move the camera in even
more visceral ways we've got seven
cranes nine scissor lifts 180 light
panels dozens and dozens of huge lights
and manitos and forklifts I mean it it's
Disneyland out there and that's what it
takes to make it look the way we need it
to look we had a lot of explosions that
we needed to do on the ship and I kept
telling my special effects guy I want
that thing to be 50 gallons of gas
rolling and it was funny because they
kept asking me how big do you want it
how many you want and I said the bigger
the better and the only limitations we
had out there was our imagination so we
kept increasing the size of the
bombs the ship deck was something that
was important because we needed scale
and we had the motorcycle sequence that
was going to be on there and we needed
speed I'm doubling Jason Stan the man is
badass so I'm just giving it all I can
to kind of make his character be as he
is a total weapon Robbie Madison came in
to do some Motocross riding for us some
some big jumps that we wanted to put on
this big aircraft carrier ship to try
and create a dynamic set piece that
would kind of make you really sit back
and think that's kind of crazy on a big
ship in the middle of the ocean at night
the scene here I got the bad guys on my
back they're shooting at me I've chucked
the 180 there's one bad guy left so I'm
coming towards him I'm popping a wheel
he's shooting at theide of the
[Applause]
motorcycle the guy's a true professional
he respects Jason a lot and I think he
wanted to go to the next level for him
you can let the emotions take on you can
get
overwhelmed my whole thing was to try
and get the bike inverted and upside
down so when I rotate around the guns on
the bike pointing
down and it all happened perfectly to be
able to bring my expertise of what I've
trained to do my whole life and be able
to put into a film and combined with all
these amazing other talents I mean I'm
living the
dream Expendables is a franchise that
you come to enjoy yourself you're
looking to get Thrills and I feel like
we've been able to accomplish the fun
factor in this movie we here to save the
world you guys just sit back and relax
we'll take care of the ugly stuff or
will we go watch the movie to find out
[Music]